[Musique]
pauvre
m
et mme taton zone
mais
koné propres experts
[Musique]
toi
jamais
pas commun
sk
m
[Musique]
ce que tu as
es tu
juppé
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
pareil
mon bon ménage
[Musique]
ou pas
désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
achat
trichet
quand
[Musique]
oh
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
tout cela
[Musique]
par le muret
non
[Musique]
joséphine rouge et noir ans avec leur
dégoût de la vie
cocteau ça se bouscule dans les couloirs
des voyages viennent sa voix tout le
monde et qu'on attendait du mois
[Musique]
mais plus comme sa version
pour ben ali
[Musique]
elle
m
[Musique]
une en alsace
nous
[Musique]
bonne nouvelle
mais voilà
non
[Musique]
roger loin pour eux seuls de reflet d'un
miroir ne prend pas une excuse
[Musique]
aucune
vérifiez de travail
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
toile américaine
à tout moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez ces baltringues les
faits ayant téléphoné toi n'ont jamais
vu mon message à nos maisons
[Musique]
un peloton you
tout en chantant c'est là
[Musique]
le champ
touchant
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que tu fais soir d'affaires ankara route
tu viens de chez et car force est
d'accord tu me rappelles cégep à la
tchéquie 6 à 20 heures je vais pas
rappeler considère que c'est rappeler
que tu veux jouer a fermé deux heures
j'ai habité jusqu'à 3 heures bye bye les
galères on va changer si fish quartier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ce soit
faire sa place pas
[Musique]
tous
on oublie tout
on est branché sur la radio dans la
voiture un homme très lourd à la
bah tout noir jantes excel dit écoute tu
as vu julien ces derniers jours chez
hervé parent pour sa santé sas paris
alain
détour son téléphone doit être coupé en
et fo ont cru très fort thalys
décroche pas j'aurai besoin de te parler
jacques ne viens pas ici tout
c'est
sois bon sens
puis je ne
ce soir ça
et on
[Musique]
à
faire sa place
nous
m
à tous
tous
[Musique]
elle fixe c'est son problème tel père
fini c'est moche quand même de tendresse
ça fait pas de mal ça aide à garder le
moral
tapie n'a 4,7 de blondie ou tablette
fini les bois 5h30 on a tous poussé chez
albert by les galères on va changer ma
promo sphère privée min j ai mon le
quartier dès que je parle
j'avais besoin de te parler
japy ne vient pas seul
soit on sort
et vous
ce soir là
ça
[Musique]
5h du mat j'ai des frissons je claque
des temps je monte le son seul sur le
lit dans mes draps bleus froisser ses
l'insomnie sommeil cassé je perds la
tête et une cigarette sont toutes fumée
dans le cendrier s'est plaint de clean
accepte ça irrite je suis tout seul tout
seul tout seul
pendant de boulogne se désespère j'ai de
quoi mon ampli rhin terre divers
plaque felber en tombant sur le lino je
me coupe la main ramassant les manceaux
jeu stérile
murs qui dansent l'alcool ça grise et ça
commence sont des moutons sur le parti
je crois que j'ai envie là
jean
[Musique]
sybille est au bout
jean
[Musique]
on vire les étoiles
6h du mat faut que je trouve à boire
liqueurs fortes au café noir je vole un
feu rouge police patrouille je serre les
fesses il ya rien qui presse 4 5 francs
maros cri le petit chose dans le matin
rouge garde mon ondine sous ses
comptines tout près d'une poste ya un
petit bar je pousse sa porte et je viens
m'asseoir 3,4 patibulaire peuple le
carton
cette pression dans les bars
[Musique]
c
légende c'est manning la décalcomanie 7h
du mat l'hôtel je paie j'abrège je
fouille mes poches
je sais c'est moche son sourire rouge
son corps qui bouge elle fait glisser
son coeur croisé sur sa peau bronzée à
des bas nylon qui filent serait de redon
saison de m'accroche tu viens chéri le
lit qui craquait les vallées claque seul
dans le lit dans ses rab le froid c'est
sur sa police mais doit glace et elle
prend la pose dans sa hotte choses c ie
miroir renvoie mon regard des anges
précédents ceux que gas et me disent
c'est l'heure
je leur dis quelle heure
[Musique]
non
ce métier ya la thèse
depuis
[Musique]
mon dieu je peux même pas jouer tant pis
pour toi il faut dormir
thomas matin
venkat jo et pas de taxis et jackie star
de petits gros des mimos les petits
bateaux relâcherait je me sens babel les
bigoudis sommes plus en vue
mon studio j'aspire à coeur je me dis
yom fait un peu peur
m
mais
oui ça
oui de match et des fruits sans je
claque des dents et je monte le sens
solide mais parfois c'est là
y sommes mais cassée j'appelle la tête
mais ces gars
sans doute fumée dans le
grelier spike lee n'excède bouteilles
vides je suis tout seul tu te sens tu te
à remplir un dernier revers claqué
devrait entendre les mots je le couple à
maromme sens limoges
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autrement dit on perd
bonnand com
d'autriche au large de
big star
cohen trafiquants
voir kaka des fonds
je fais tout
en terre étrangère
[Musique]
ok
dans le corps
mosquée
la plaie
[Musique]
jean
pour toi
était pas
[Musique]
oh
ap
[Musique]
nous sommes
gagnon
monsieur
faire
trente ans
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
genou
c
et
l'entente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi
non
quittons
aubry
l'assaut
son parcours
[Musique]
suis pas en phase
j'ai un
[Applaudissements]
et je déconne
et on
e
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà
à
tous
à tous
[Musique]
quoi
jma
[Musique]
moi
ouais
[Applaudissements]
pour tout parent
[Musique]
tous
mais
j'attendais
le
[Musique]
qui
cabine
et vous
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous ai pas
la passion commune
oh
cisco
[Musique]
oui
d
[Musique]
a paris il ya une semaine
vous
ça
il y a
[Musique]
le temps
t
[Musique]
sow
com
m
[Musique]
non
ge qui s'achève
oui
mais son rêve
[Musique]
et
mais
emo
pas trop fort
[Musique]
m
des moments
[Musique]
tout le temps
et
[Musique]
oh
c
[Musique]
des vitrines
rouge
des et sofremi
jamais
[Musique]
c
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens
[Musique]
hamon
moi je suis
souley
c
du coup
l écart
g
une jolie 100
finances raymond bachand 1er mai
moi
[Musique]
à jeu
la coi
m
à genoux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
ma part au bout
à
tous
[Musique]
fumay
moi je
[Musique]
mais moi
à ce
il
hu
ora
[Applaudissements]
bon
ep
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poulet
[Musique]
jama
je
m
[Musique]
moi j'aime ça
on a senti
[Musique]
moi même
[Applaudissements]
chanter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime pas
m
k
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
agaçant
m
oh
[Musique]
car
comment
ciao
[Musique]
des bottes
des garde temps
je suis
dix ans
en place d
des garçons
[Musique]
k
besset
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dec
[Musique]
deux accidents
je te plaît
sept ans
[Musique]
non
avant
le sillon
en
b
[Musique]
m
de la bosse des maths des magazines des
maris les perles et marie-claire défilé
mal mais pas très peur des femmes
d'aujourd'hui et d'hier c'est la beauté
mathema quasi des marines est censé
marie-france des pas pratique y en aura
martégaux bazar
[Musique]
on sait
ils sont
les garçons
m
et à sang
non
[Musique]
treki qui sait
la terne
farès il
m
[Musique]
je veux aller
qui
ça
et
je joue
[Musique]
respectueux
mais on
pâques
[Musique]
je
dans un an
kim avant
que c'est
[Musique]
je vous la musique ed
quoi son piano
je sois là
[Musique]
six brasseries
santé
je viens
[Musique]
iata
guillon et sentiments
m
saca
[Musique]
et je t'attends
y'a plus gros pirates 2
si grand
[Musique]
on
il n'y a pas
[Musique]
m
à
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voisin d'en face est parti et avec lui
mais soirée de folie pour salino bleuté
reste chez moi crochet dans l'entré nuit
brésilienne
paris c'était la folie les étoiles du
ciel à meylan
on joue lumière
[Musique]
bien sûr les quais paris
c'est la folie des lapins
jusqu'au petit matin on n'est pas
les partis pour voyager
il n'a pas de terre à ses souliers oui
vous californie
il ne sait toujours pas où il fera
sonner nuit brésilienne
paris c'était la folie les étoiles du
ciel
joe lumière rendent un peu de ça
eh bien
sur les quais parisiens
c'est la folle idée
jusqu'au petit matin on est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il reviendra comme le corcovado les bras
en croix et il me demande
où est ce qu'on va pour danser la samba
et on dira
pour manger des glaces ou pas le
président
c'est de la folie c'est la folie des
latins
jusqu'au petit matin on est tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je goodman
m
[Musique]
je vois
car les zac portail
delamarre
pas de là jusqu'au ciel
m
là faut pas pousser
je vous la maladie
pour la
piketty
pas du tout
toujours là
déjà les mois
[Musique]
à marennes
l'accès
la chanson
m
[Musique]
ou pas
c'est bien le cas
[Musique]
où
je re ou demain
na li à nous battre
m
[Musique]
ce thème
je vous dis
mais pas pour la
où est le double
accoyer
assemat là bas
je peux la reine
la conseil
[Musique]
la contacter
l'ania
je n'ai
voilà voilà
à
art
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il regarde sa ville tranquille
il attend
qui sait qu'il est fragile
difficile et pourtant il vous faut c'est
gros yeux
airgas avant
[Musique]
le chômage a sonné
un genre
pas
[Musique]
cet horizon de tous
qui l'entourent
l' asphyxie sont
m
passez les jours dits l'ennui
ce n'est qu'un enfant
qui rêve de po
donnez lui
n'est ce pas
ceux ci
et beaulieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
mais bon
[Musique]
non
st
pendu
[Musique]
de casser en café avec des amis
il passe son temps
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il se souvient
joue avec le feu
j'ouvre délinquants
[Musique]
qu'ils soient méchants
deux mondes
[Musique]
sa place
ceci dit
le froid
17 ans
il a
on fait la somme
sur le mans
et
la police lui
ses parents s'inquiètent
comme dans un
au mans
c'est ton nom
c'est le centre
[Musique]
c'est toi qu il
moulin
oui
[Musique]
que nous
m6
mon dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]